the big story as of this morning is that
elon musk the tesla guy the spacex guy
the boring company guy yeah that guy
right there uh the original co-founder
co-creator of paypal along with peter
thiel
he now is on the board of twitter i
covered it yesterday that he bought a
9.2 state 9.2 stake in twitter we've got
some info here from forbes
tesla ceo elon musk has acquired a 9.2
stake in twitter the social media giant
disclosed in an sec filing on monday a
move that comes weeks after the
billionaire accused twitter of failing
to adhere to free speech principles
2.8 billion 2.89 billion that's how much
musk's twitter stocks were worth based
on friday's closing twitter stock price
surged 27 on monday i mean this guy is
such a baller that when he buys
something he spends about three billion
of his own money and then the stock all
rises so then it's as if he spent less
money on it right and the whole point of
of everything that he's been about over
the last i don't know a couple months at
least is that he's trying to fight for
free speech he's been asking is twitter
you know banning people are they
respecting free speech and all of these
things um so now that he is on the board
so now he he is the largest stakeholder
but he's not a majority stakeholder
right he doesn't own 51 percent so he
can't just do whatever he wants to do
but he is the largest stakeholder he
actually replaced morgan stanley as the
number one stakeholder in twitter
um he is going to be on the board he
will be able to make decisions he will
be able to ask questions hey why did we
kill that hunter biden story who did
that did we have any uh contact with the
government on that who who killed that
story is that something that anyone has
asked around here uh he might say hey
how did we decide to get rid of that
donald trump guy does anyone uh know how
we made that final decision or babylon b
is suspended one of the biggest satire
sites in the united states they're
suspended right now or how about this
one uh that tucker carlson guy uh is
suspended right now all he did was say
that there's differences between uh men
and women males and females he's the
largest cable news talk show highest
rated cable news talk show host in
history of cable news uh should he be
suspended on our platform elon might
start asking these questions hey how
come dave rubin was suspended in july
for saying that vaccine mandates might
be coming from the federal government
because he ended up being right about
that why'd we suspend him on that one
elon you got your work cut out for you
man but if anyone's up to it it's you so
the point is that that there is some
goodness here there there is some
goodness because good people have to
enter the fight
this is what i've been to this is why i
started locals good people after fight
build a better product this is what's
going on over at the daily wire why'd
they do jeremy's razors it's like okay
harry's razors you want to go woke we'll
build our own razor company and sell
them and it sounds like they're already
bigger than harry's razors this is why
you build alternative networks like the
blaze this is why prageru is now doing
prageru kids and daily wires doing daily
wire kids enough of this [ __ ] enough
of this [ __ ] we'll expose it we'll
mock it and then we'll move on so i
don't know that we're quite at the move
on phase but the second we are i will be
the first one to move on i assure you
and i will not talk about any of this
nonsense anymore but we have to somehow
expose it still and mock it as we build
uh for now this cold close
about the board meeting that's happening
at twitter right now
what do you think of him
he's a pedantic pontificating
pretentious bastard a belligerent old
fart a worthless steaming pile of cow
dung
figuratively speaking
you